cheers let's see what happens
ten episodes
you two bring in your most prized
collectibles from childhood
now you will display your prized
collectibles from childhood and describe
the astonishing nature of their
importance to you
this is treasure treasures begin
okay
so last week
dudesy gives us little things to do at
the end of episodes and last week dudesy
told me to bring in my most prized
possessions from childhood for a show
and tell i'm now going to do that so let
me show you what i brought today oh boy
you've got a lot of stuff going on as as
a child of the 80s i know that
you're kind of a dork for a lot of
different things what are you doing
there what do you got there oh my gosh
he's got a bunch of for anyone who's not
watching he's pulled out a bunch of
bunch of trading cards playing cards
what
um these are magic the gathering cards
oh man
now for anybody who played magic the
gathering or knows anything about it
the beta set the second full set that
was ever released back in 1993 is kind
of the holy grail of magic cards they
were the first cards that they
differentiated from the alpha set
because the corners were more squared in
the beta set and that squared kind of
corner is what was used in every set
after that so beta is like technically
the first series of cards that's like
playable tournament legal well that's
really interesting that you go right to
the [ __ ] minutia of this super
[ __ ] nerdy thing
chad you nerd um now another thing that
made this is this is one of my beta
cards this is maha modi gin and it's a
uh psa graded mint nine and as you can
also see beta cards had these black
borders which for a little while because
after them uh the main set was unlimited
then revise fourth edition so on and so
forth they all had white borders so
these black border cards people all
wanted them in their decks and these
became very hard to get because again
this was one of the first sets ever made
and a lot of people just threw them away
put them in their [ __ ] bikes and
their spokes to do whatever unreal and
these cards um begin to disappear so how
how old were you when these things
came out 37
no it was 1993 how [ __ ] old was i
dude you were six freshman 17 yeah 16 17
that sounds about right and my friends
and i would play this [ __ ] in high
school all the time here's like all of
these and um over the course of all
these over the course of my life these
are all the ones that i have bought off
ebay that are in like their little you
know their little things some elven
archers we got an ankamishra we got a
[ __ ] brain geyser yeah
you got a long commissioner got a
[ __ ] balance that was one of my
favorite cards of all time
yeah macho might want to read the text
on that card
now you're trying to do the same thing
that doozy
makes us do yeah
any source when you got the laminate
that makes it hard to read yeah
any sorcery or instant spell
just cast is doubled yeah that's twice
the power of the mega powers yup
treat what trait fork
treat fork as an exact copy of target
spell except that fork remains red yeah
red yellow orange and yellow
copy and original original may have
different targets i'm bored yeah yeah
dude here's one you might like yeah
i liked brother oh yeah yeah
why don't you show that to people uh-huh
yeah this is what does berserk do yeah
this is dessert brother yeah that
becomes after you eat dinner and they
say can i tempt you with a dessert yeah
no i'm watching my carbohydrates uh and
it says until the end uh until end
until end of turn target creatures
current power yeah
doubles as it gains
trample abrabary there's a bunch of dumb
words
[Music]
okay
well how many of these things do you
[ __ ] have now he's got a box he has a
stack of like his favorite favorites i
guess these are these are in the little
cases yeah they look like these take
them out it looks like an old school it
looks like a cross between it's like the
size of an old cassette but it's in a
case like a cd yeah anybody who collects
cards knows all about this nobody's the
rest nobody's box this is all my beta
set i've been trying to complete a beta
set for probably my whole life basically
and i got just in the habit of
collecting it maybe 10 years ago or so i
haven't added to it in a while i think
i'm like about 50 cards shy and most of
them are the big ones the power 9 if you
know anything about that we're talking
about the moxen the black lotus time
walk time twister
i know it's it's very boring to you but
dudesy has asked me to do this so i will
continue what is your problem i'm
sitting here uh-huh i'm just sitting
here like
these are some of my my best cards of
the set
you know all lands and play are
destroyed yeah that's amazing all lands
are destroyed that sounds something like
[ __ ] badlands right there all the
dual lands if you'll remember bruce
springsteen magic the gathering card i
guess there's a bayou
goddamn this is like creedence
clearwater it's a [ __ ] paradise
what's that birds of paradise yeah uh
that's a david lee right
tap to add one man of any color to your
menopause just like this all right
what's it called
something paradise birds of paradise
paradise
[Music]
this one is one of the best cards that
was ever invented in magic the gathering
i'm trying to show it to the camera
there we go and it's called chaos orb
this card would allow you to drop it
from a certain height and any cards that
it touched in the in the playing field
would be destroyed
and so there was lore of a guy who in a
tournament ripped one of these cards up
and spread the confetti over the entire
thing and destroy the other guy's entire
stash of course could you do that
nobody knows if that was true or at
least i don't know if that was actually
true but that was the lore and so for
these reasons a lot of these cards got
banned in subsequent sets they stopped
making them which uh is why a lot of
them became super valuable i'm gonna
show you my pride hey you hear that i
don't know if you heard that siren over
there but if you're listening you hear
the sirens and nerd police coming
it's not dude
i mean yeah whatever so how long have
you been collecting these things check
this [ __ ] out okay this is my best card
that i own oh mox emerald there were
five of these one for each color if you
know anything about magic five colors
are kind of what it's based on yeah and
this is the green one you can it's like
the chakras right yeah
kind of each of the colors is it like
corresponds to a land type so like white
is planes black is swamps red is mounds
blue is islands green is forests but
they put out these artifacts in beta
that were zero casting costs meaning you
could drop them on the table immediately
and tap them for
these these mocks marks do they ever
have like you named all these different
things that they ever have one that's
like
like uh
like uh lucky charms oops all marks
well there was a diamond mocks that came
out in a later mocks
dude mocks just like john moxley you
know what he said no he said
before i stand side by side with anybody
i'm gonna bleed with them first that was
john mark dude
you're understanding the weight of what
you're witnessing right now i know that
they're worth a few bucks right the beta
set is
no i mean there are very few in
existence this isn't even a complete one
i would love to complete this eventually
unfortunately like the black lotus for
example is the most expensive magic card
ever made the beta black lotus is the
most expensive version of that they
existed in alpha beta and unlimited and
uh every once in a while you'll see on
ebay like a highly graded beta black
lotus floating around for like 90 grand
or something are you serious yeah and so
like that's a card that i'm never going
to have i have to reconcile that and
accept it but this game at various
points in my life has
you know played certain roles i suppose
when i went to college i was in like a
magic the gathering [ __ ] club and we
would go play at the costa mesa women's
center every [ __ ] sunday and we went
to the pro tour when it was on the queen
marriage show i know you're [ __ ]
laughing but that [ __ ] was fun dude yeah
it was like um i i find myself every
once in a while being an active member
of certain nerd dumps pokemon go was
another one when that game first came
out yeah man
for it you also don't like to get my
friend chad doesn't like to get cold so
i remember you had uh gloves so you
could go out and do pokemon go in the
winter time and you could touch the
screen you could sleep without exactly
so while you're running around uh
santa monica pier yeah as it's freezing
at seven o'clock at night
but these cards to some degree are like
representative at least to me of this
part of my childhood it's like i also
have a street fighter 2 arcade game
sitting in my living room oh it's a
similar kind of like i i just like to
have this this piece of my childhood
that was very important to me then i
collect it now i don't really play magic
much anymore i have a couple of friends
who still will like have games every
once in a while and we'll just [ __ ]
around but i was hyper competitive about
it in college i was like on a team and
[ __ ] you were you were what yeah dude
you were on a team yeah dude was that
like an official school team like you'd
play other schools it wasn't official
but i've heard now that like some high
schools and [ __ ] have magic the
gathering teams oh that's a problem you
know why is it a [ __ ] problem well
i'll tell you what your problem is you
have two [ __ ] many of them and that's
what makes you a nerd
what
i'm just saying
i have the whole set you have to have
the whole [ __ ] set yeah yeah yeah
yeah that yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
magic here
the marks cards yeah
there's only but if you have the betamax
card yeah that's worth more
you see that's because it's a
marks that pay the max nobody even gave
a [ __ ] about it everybody was on the vhs
nobody wanted oh my god nobody want to
watch hercules my first movie
i is some dorky stuff you know i mean
but but this is
i don't know am i being a jerk by saying
i don't mean like i think nerds are
great nerds are cool but you're
i think like we all collect [ __ ] you
know or i don't
okay you collect nothing
i don't collect anything oh uh
uh coffee cups i've been collecting
coffee cups lately so you're a coffee
cup nerd all right
coffee cup nerd no i'm just saying i'm
just saying that
this is uh this is a lot this is a lot
for me to oh dude this is like
1 1 000th of my entire collection
what yeah
come on i have full sets of like a bunch
of recent sets i'll just [ __ ] nab
anytime a new set comes out i'll just
like [ __ ] pick one up off ebay and i
go through
periods where i'm collecting more
hardcore than than i am other times you
know whatever but uh it's something that
i don't know there's a nostalgic piece
of magic cards to me that will always
exist i think and i like them and i like
having these cards it was fun for me to
even just like look back through these
these were in a drawer in my house so i
haven't looked at them in a minute
that's cool
here's here's the and i'm not trying to
be super practical and i'm not trying to
make fun of you okay
thanks what
what the heck are you gonna do with all
those i don't know just have them dude
all right i like having them yeah but
doesn't it isn't it all cluttery don't
you want to get rid of all these things
i have you know i got all sorts of crap
i'd like to get rid of okay that i can't
because sure maybe i'll sell them one
day i don't know
i got a bunch of speaking of vhs i got a
bunch of vhs tapes that i just can't get
rid of i need like a vhs nerd dude hold
on dude why i got a lot of uh videos
they don't have on the network brother
so you got to have them on vhs and you
got to have them on dvd dude what dvds
and vhs's do you have that you can't get
on streaming we don't need to talk about
that this is your segment okay oh is it
oh
thank you moving on
please tell a friend
here's what you do
please tell a friend then break a
preview
if you like dudes here's what you do
[Music]
please celebrate and then